tell us where Tony Stark is in his life
when this film opens and tell us about
his role with the Avengers now Tony is
basically hosting the Avengers in his
Tower in New York Avengers tower I
believe it's called now stark tower
which is really Avengers Tower and and
he's working on a system that will make
it so that the Avengers really don't
have to do what they've been doing all
along which purportedly should be the
end game describe the feeling that you
guys have the chemistry you have as a
cast and getting back together again
with everybody for this time around well
I don't think any of us really expected
how huge the first one would be so it
can almost intimidate you a bit because
you're like oh well we were just kind of
hoping it would work out and now there's
this expectation to deliver so but the
nice thing is it really is a great cast
of folks and we genuinely enjoy making
this entertainment together what is it
about Tony as a character that attracts
you to to come back to him again and
again and involve him as you do it was
just this perfect storm of feeling like
I could create the character within the
guidelines of what he was always
supposed to be and I just thought he was
so cool when I was reading the comic
books I was like great so let's just
keep it real human and and make sure
that there's enough wit in there so that
people don't think he's a stiff and I
think it'll work out alright every
Marvel film brings something new and
different to its audience what were you
hoping that Avengers age of Ultron would
bring to the audience's this time around
well again you know the obviously new
folks is great you know like having
Elizabeth and Aaron having Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver and having Paul Bettany
who's Ben Jarvis all the time get to do
something new and James Spader I thought
was just a brilliant piece of casting
for Ultron you always you always hope
that it just defies expectation and then
I guess this time around we just really
wanted people
to not say well that's alright the first
one was great so we saw it anyway you
know what is it about the dynamic
between you and Joss Whedon that allows
you guys to create those moments that
you do in these films well it's a
respect you know and every director
actor relationship is so different and
Joss is a is very in control and really
wants to have authorship over things so
I think for me it was about just being a
little bit more receptive and it makes
it in some ways just makes the job
easier because he's kind of got it
figured out
you